rookie alec manoa has been unbelievable
for charlie montoya and the toronto blue
jays and he makes his 10th start of the
season tonight there's jd martinez and
bluejay saw him about cleanup
when they were in boston but he is back
in his more familiar third spot in the
order manila comes home swinging a
ground ball out to machete waiting on
ended short goes to simeon for one the
pivot to first in time double play to
retire this side nathan avaldi's the
wins leader for the red sox with nine
victories in a 371 earned run average
the veteran right-hander will throw for
boston it's time to buckle up now
because here comes the red-hot bo bachet
two and two the pitch to beschette swing
and a high fly into center field kk
racing back in front of the track he's
there to make the play and the inning is
over that was loud but
vivaldi gets through it
rbi opportunity for jd martinez the o2
martinez bounces the ball towards the
middle of the diamond picked up by
machete offbounds throw to first stretch
by vlady in time to get the out
what an athletic play on both ends far
ranging to the glovehand side in the
middle of the diamond on the move beshet
lets it go and vladimir guerrero jr
stepping into the splits
verdugo will take third base on the play
and there's one out bogarts with a
runner at third and one out and the blue
jays will bring the infield in
here's the 2-0
swing and a high fly into right center
field it's deep enough to get the run in
hernandez is in front of the warning
track he's there to make the play
verdugo can trot home sac fly for
bogarts and it's one nothing red sox
rafael devers will hit
devers lines went softly out to simeon
in the ship who ranges to the glovehand
side and makes a sprawling catch to
retire the side
a rangy play by the blue jay second
baseman
able to track down that soft liner in
shallow right field
nice job
boy the defense that marcus simeon has
played all season long has been elite
middle of the fourth one nothing boston
and with runners on first and second
here is
[ __ ] hernandez tk yesterday oh for two
but he did walk a couple times
he's homered walked four times and
tripled on the road trip
big spot here two on two out
one ball two strikes
here's the pitch
swing and a drive into left center field
it is gonna sink in there for a hit
marwin rounds third he will score alas
it's a hit with a runner in scoring
position and the red sox lead it two to
nothing
that will load the bases
for jd martinez
bases loaded and the 02
hit in the air shallow on the right side
underneath it guerrero still on the clay
makes the catch to retire the side
alec manoa able to minimize the damage
in the fifth inning boston only gets one
and the red sox leave them loaded
middle of the fifth
red sox claiming a two-nothing lead over
the blue jays randall grichik digs in
rudder at second blue jays trailing two
nothing the pitch
swinging the ball looped down the right
field line twisting towards the corner
twisting down for a base hit kirk saw it
to the turf he sprints towards third
he's coming around to score on an rbi
double for randall grinchik
toronto is on the board
and they've cut the lead in half
now breivik valera the one-two pitch
swinging a line drive up the right field
line that's a fair ball
grichik is in to tie the game on an rbi
double by valera
the blue jays have bladed nathan of
baldi for three straight doubles here in
the fifth inning and have tied the game
here is simeon who has doubled down the
left field line and grounded out to
third the o2 is a slider outside did he
go yes he did strike three on a swing
and simeon is gone
here's bo buchet
runners on the corners in a tie game the
2-2 and the air out to deep right field
renfro push back he's on the run turns
around and it's off the wall valera is
in to score guerrero runs to third on an
rbi base hit
by bobachet
cole buchet with his 38th multiple hit
game so first and third again with the
blue jays leading three to two and
here's teo star hernandez
oscar hernandez swings at the first
pitch and he slams it into the gap in
the left center field it goes to the
warning track guerrero's in to score
bushette is flying to the plate the
relay throw is late
two run double for t oscar hernandez
a five run fifth
for toronto
ninth hitter to the plate in the form of
lourdes curiel junior
as curiel jumps on the first pitch
hooking down the line and it is
gone
it's gone
the rogers center is alive again
the blue jays have batted around
a seven run fifth inning
and the knockout punch from lourdes
gorilla junior hansel robles onto the
mound at rogers center and now randall
grichik who himself doubled in a run
what seems like a long while ago in this
inning
and rando gets hit
and that's kind of suspect
robles new to the red sox
comes in and hits grichik
on the elbow pad montoya is out of the
dugout
and he's going to umpires are
having a meeting this is interesting
they could eject robles if they believe
there was intent on that pitch
though gettings is the crew chief
and they have just issued a warning
and now
the blue jays are upset
and everybody's coming out of the game
and cora gets to robles as
robles came over toward the blue jays
dugout and now jim wolf is saying hey
you blue jays get back in the dugout
george springer
that's for the second time here in this
fifth
the pitch to springer
swinging a line drive down the left
field line hooking into the corner and
that is a fair ball
kirk comes home to score bridgex into
score
and the ball hops out of
the field of play for an automatic
double in the corner
the blue jays have tallied nine times
twice struck out against manoa 3-2 pitch
swinging a drive to left field this ball
is pounded and it is way gone renfro
leans into one and
maybe just maybe
that's the spark the red sox needed two
run homer for renfro and it's nine to
four well it doesn't hurt it doesn't
hurt it gets some momentum going back on
there made some good vibes going back to
them
the oscar delivered a two-run double
back in the fifth inning
9-4 toronto the pitch
pounding ball towards the middle of
diamond past the dive of bogarts into
center field simeon comes in to score
and the blue jays have hit double
figures
10 runs tonight
hernandez has driven home three infield
back outfield deep lined up straight
away against springer
this home stand has featured george
doing everything defensively hitting for
thunder
and driving the ball all over the place
there's another drive he'll place it in
right center field this time down for a
base hit cut off in the alley and then
lost in between hernandez and renfro
grichik is all the way around from first
to score and springer trots into third
standing
rbi number three on the night
and an extra base hit again for george
springer and we're going to get a treat
here with jonathan already the position
player player pitching
alejandro kirk has a couple of hits
tonight two for three
arus now to alejandro kirk
he'll whack one in the air down the
right field line off into the corner
renfro is there to make the catch
tagging at third hernandez speeding
towards the plate he'll score
guards over two with a sacrifice flying
a walk two out nobody on the one two
a little bouncing ball out to short bow
waiting on it back hands cox back fires
to first in time to finish the ball game
you